bonsoir nouvelle semaine sur tv fil 78
pour le 7-8 votre rendez vous quotidien
avec l'actualité des yvelines ce soir je
reçois tout d'abord françois fontaine
bonsoir vous êtes la proviseure du lycée
louis blériot et jean pierre félix vous
êtes le chef de travaux de cet
établissement
vous venez d'organiser la cérémonie de
récompenses du prix de rock et riz pour
vos élèves qui se sont illustrés lors de
cette finale internationale c'est à
londres en juillet dernier finale de
lancer de fusées en quelque sorte on
reviendra sur le détail dans un instant
mais déjà un mot peut-être du proviseur
quel sentiment vous avez reçu vous avez
eu pardon quand vous leur avez remis ce
prix à ses élèves c'est une première
pour un établissement français de
recevoir ce prix de roquettes rider
c'est une première pour un établissement
français semaine première tout court
parce que c'était ma propriété chasse
gardée des américains depuis la création
du concours une immense fierté et qui
était partagé certaines une fierté au
niveau de l'établissement mais de la
part de ses élèves aussi c'est quelque
chose qui était que des flagrants
demande de remise de récompenses en
présence du petit fils qu'on peut
apercevoir sur les images de 2001 ray
ozzie a donné son nom à l'établissement
même fierté pour le chef de travaux de
l'établissement qui a accompagné ses
élèves sur ce projet d'euro catry
absolument se montrer très fier d'eux et
toute l'équipe vous restez avec nous on
va reparler de ce prix on va parler
également de vos projets et ils sont
nombreux pour cet établissement louis
blériot à trappes
nous reviendrons également ce soir avec
notre prochaine invitée titoune sur la
sortie de son premier album c'est un
artiste compositeur auteur chanteur du
département vous saurez tout sur son
premier album rêves de gamin et puis la
page de ce sport comme chaque lundi la
chronique sport avec anthony rech bon
soir anthony saliou wilfried ce soir au
programme une édition spéciale une page
spéciale sur la coupe de france de
football nous analyserons les fortunes
diverses des clubs saint quentinois qui
était encore en lice ce week-end et ne
recevront d'ailleurs le capitaine des
moins de 19 ans du football olympique de
plaisir aussi nous parlerons de football
américain des templiers d'elancourt avec
le président qui sera avec nous qu'ils
préparent sagement leur saison après
leur belle montée et une petite surprise
en fin de chronique avec cet invité je
ne vous en dis pas plus mais on peut
dire qu'il y aura des pompons et de la
musique
mais quel sens plusieurs et qu'elles
sont plusieurs j'ai beaucoup avant 10
pour éventuellement trouver de quoi il
s'agit
comme d'habitude les résultats du
week-end tous les résultats bien sûr
tout savoir sur le sport du week end
lors de la chronique sport dont une
quinzaine de minutes
nous allons à présent passer aux
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
29 octobre en images la fête de l'aïd el
kébir pour les musulmans c'était ce
vendredi là nous avons suivi une prière
à saint cyr l'école l'association locale
en a profité pour réaffirmer sa
détermination à voir se créer une
mosquée sur le secteur les communes ont
en charge l'organisation de la vie
scolaire et du temps extrascolaire toute
une réflexion qui a fait l'objet d'
assises autour de l'éducation cela s'est
déroulé aux clayes-sous-bois et puis on
sport en coupe de france de football
week-end difficile pour les clubs locaux
nous disions il ya quelques instants
versailles s'est incliné au 6e tour face
aux lilas beaucoup de temps bardella
guyancourt a gagné face à
verrières-le-buisson plaisir a perdu
face à saint leu à magny-les-hameaux il
fallait aimer courir dans l'eau froid ce
dimanche pour le trail des sept hameaux
troisième édition mille concurrents sur
la ligne de départ
1 le vainqueur du 27 km et licencié à
versailles il s'appelle jonathan trio m
et a couru on n'en peut plus de deux
heures est la plus grande fête de la
communauté musulmane s'est donc déroulée
vendredi la fête de l'aïd el kébir cette
année dans une ambiance particulière
entre tensions au niveau national et
absence d'abattoirs mobile dans le
département des yvelines
alice gastines patrick jacques de
dixmude se sont rendus auprès des
musulmans de saint cyr l'école et de
fontenay le fleury et qui s'inquiètent
également de leur côté de l'absence de
mosquées sur leur secteur
vendredi 26 octobre 2012 ce jour de fête
dans la communauté musulmane de censure
l'école fontenay-le-fleury c'est l'aïd
el kébir jour où l'on commémore la
soumission d'abraham à dieu mais malgré
l'ambiance de fête les mines sont
soucieuses le projet de construction
d'une mosquée et d'un centre culturel à
l'iss
mick tournoi surtout sur la commune de
saint cyr c est nécessaire d'avoir un
lieu de culte comme les mosquées
la c4 on a cessé partout on avait pas
mal d'années ça fait 10 juin on attend
non seulement il était nécessaire mais
il est indispensable car nous avons
beaucoup de familles de s'inspirer de
fontenay qui sont obligés d'aller dans
les mosquées avoisinantes
aujourd'hui les familles sont dispersés
dans tout ces mosquées la une est
vraiment triste qu'elle ne sont pas
réunies dans un seul lieu c'est ce
terrain qui a été retenue par les
différentes parties
problème il est situé à la fois sur les
communes de saint cyr l'école et de
fontenay-le-fleury le foncier appartient
à la mairie de fontenay mais pour
l'exploiter il faudrait modifier le plan
local d'urbanisme de saint cyr hier soir
j'ai eu monsieur le maire monsieur
bernard de bain au téléphone il m'a dit
qu'il n'était pas contre de ce projet
mais qu'il fallait refaire revoir le
paie lui une consultation publique devra
donc être organisées avant toute
modification du pays et lui ce qui peut
prendre du temps
à cela s'ajoute l'échéance électorale je
pense que la période avant 2014 est une
période où naturellement on ne va pas
lancer un projet qui ferait qui se
raccrocherait à de la politique
politicienne mais certainement pas sur
le fond les musulmans qui ont pour
l'instant collecter un cinquième de la
somme nécessaire à la construction du
bâtiment espèrent être dans les murs
d'ici trois ans le bâtiment coûte en
totalité un million et demi d'euros
le lieu de culte s'adresserait aux 1200
familles musulmanes de saint cyr
fontenay et bois d'arcy soit 4000
fidèles
le centre socioculturel serait quant à
lui
vers oran public et proposerait des
cours de civilisation et d'arabes une
bibliothèque ainsi que du soutien
scolaire
premiers invités de cette édition du 29
octobre du cette suite en direct si vous
nous avez rejoint à 18 heures françois
fontaine le proviseur du lycée louis
blériot et jean pierre félix le chef de
travaux de ce même établissement on le
disait tout à l'heure vous venez de
recevoir ou plutôt vos élèves quatre
élèves de votre établissement ont reçu
officiellement le 1er prix de
l'international rock et rites chalenge
médailles et trophées pour les
récompenser de leur résultat vous était
déjà venu avec avec que sur ce plateau
pour commenter un petit peu puisque les
résultats de la compétition se déroulait
du côté de londres c'était juste la
juste avant les vacances il s'agit d'un
championnat du monde de lancer de fusées
concrètement pour les élèves ils ne sont
pas là on imagine peut-être qui vous
écoute pas mais vous êtes fier d'eux
vous pensez que ça aussi changer leur
façon de travailler au quotidien dans
l'établissement ce prix tout à fait les
amener à se rendre compte que certaines
disciplines étaient essentiels alors
c'est des disciplines pour lesquelles
n'est pas forcément beaucoup d'intérêt
au début de match physique anglais ce
sont des choses qui sur lesquels ont
reposé sur qu'ils ont pu s'appuyer pour
conquérir ce titre et on a des élèves
qui est survenu au mois de juillet
durant les vacances scolaires pour
préparer leur finale internationale
oui je pense que ça a changé leur leur
approche de de l'enseignement et sur
tous leur a montré qu'ils étaient
capables eux aussi de pouvoir atteindre
un sommet atteint des sommets un titre
de champion du monde c'est quand même
quelque chose de rare ils sont fiers de
ce qu'ils ont faits sont fiers de leur
établissement aussi extrêmes rage est
extrêmement fier cliché mais peut-être
plus en tout cas de de honte de dire où
vient d'un établissement de trappes
maintenant je pense que là il ya les
hélices était aussi est-ce que ce le
fait de se dire bon voilà on est un
établissement né en banlieue parisienne
on vient de trappes
qu'est ce qu'on va faire dans cette
compétition ils l'ont accueilli comment
justement cette idée de participer au
début de l'année ils ont été je pense
fier déjà de pouvoir s'inscrire dans
cette
dans ce projet ils sont partis un petit
peu aventure sans trop savoir sans
aucune prétention humblement et je pense
qu'ils ont été vraiment très fier de
montrer ce que le lycée était capable de
produire et de porter haut les couleurs
de blériot tout à fait il y avait
vraiment une fierté
vous avez travaillé comme ans avec comme
vous avez vu cette évolution comment
vous l'avez ressenti jusqu'à jusqu'aux
premiers lancers à caen c'était un petit
peu compliqué parce qu'effectivement
pour eux il fallait qu'il conceptualise
qu'ils imaginent ce qui allait se passer
plusieurs étapes
j'évoquais la la finale très de londres
mais non il je crois que c'était un
petit peu notre la difficulté nos élèves
c'est souvent ils ont beaucoup de mal à
à l'abstraction et beaucoup de mal à
imaginer ce qu'il peut se passer
derrière une formule mathématique
derrière leur travail au quotidien le
soir
et dès le retour de caen dans la
camionnette je peux vous assurer que là
il avait compris hélas à partir de là la
motivation pour montbéliard puis après
pour fins de boro a été extrême et elle
est encore puisque trois de nos équipes
sont inscrites pour cette année sur le
challenge et m'a dit donc qui est
champion du monde a déjà pratiquement
fini les plans de sa fusée est là pour
le conclut à l'expérience et on n'a rien
besoin de lui dire ses premiers tests
sont très prometteurs vous êtes déjà
fait un g2 à deux mètres de hauteur
parce que là il ya quatre élèves qui ont
été récompensés pour ce prix qui par ce
succès sur cette édition ils vont encore
s'inscrit à participer l'année prochaine
alors une partie d'entre eux 1,2 d'entre
eux
sont encore dans l'établissement enfin
dans l'établissement et donc un est au
collège courbet voyez pas ce que j'ai
dit 4e mais effectivement il en a trois
qui étaient d'établissement est ainsi
venu je me courbe est tout à fait
puisque au sein de notre club
aéronautique je refais un petit peu
l'histoire on accueille aussi des élèves
qui souhaitent passer leurs billes à un
peu même encore on peut prendre en
prendre des inscriptions pour cette
année donc ils passent leur brevet
d'initiation aéronautique en même temps
et donc de ses élèves vont d'un club
aéronautique proposer une fusée il y
aura encore plus d'élèves inscrits pour
cette édition puisque cette troisième
saison puisque deux autres équipes sont
inscrites avec nous avec la réforme du
baccalauréat
nous avons donc de l'accompagnement
personnalisé et donc le professeur
stéphane rasé a mis en place un module
de formation
pour justement développer le challenge
est donc là sous forme de volontariat
on a un mini challenge de création de
fusées au sein de l'établissement qui en
train de se dérouler et on pense que
deux équipes arriveront à se détacher
donc on devrait pouvoir présenter avec
trois équipes dans les différentes
phases de préparation les préliminaires
pour la finale qui aura lieu à paris
alors ça a boosté les élèves ça booste
leurs résultats ça booste
l'établissement aussi il ya d'autres
projets autour de l'aéronautique de
l'aviation il ya deux ans clobert au
nautic débutait on était trois
enseignants à travailler le soir dans
l'autre camp disons qu est ce que ça
vaut vraiment le coup
et au bout de deux ans bien écouter ans
les champions du monde on a reçus le
gifas planète sciences le petit fils de
louis blériot donc est venu lui remettre
cette année le les diplômes
je dois avouer que c'est plus qu'il n'en
faut et puis on a un autre projet donc
leur greffer challenge en continu et
puis il ya le 20 novembre
nous devrions recevoir le kit d'un avion
puisque nous allons construire un
l'avion un biplace écoles de façon à ce
que nos élèves dont trois ans puisse à
obtenir un diplôme de brevet de pilote à
un prix intéressant donc ça va se passer
que la fédération rsa le réseau du sport
aérien et donc là nous allons construire
bain du 20 novembre jusqu'au jusqu'en
décembre 2014 si je me trompe dans
l'assemblage cet avion qui doit voler à
terme absolu absolument absolument c'est
un biplace c'est un zehner et dash 650
pour les patients les socialistes
auraient par la spécialiste fournée sur
internet et puis pourront suivre de
toute façon tout cela sur le blog de
l'établissement sur le blog du club
aéronautique
donc on continue notre expérience dans
l'aéronautique toujours en liaison avec
notre formation puisque nous faisons ça
aussi avec la filière maintenance
industrielle
nous associons nos élèves et du club
aéronautique et de la formation initiale
parce qu'à l'en but pédagogique dernier
évidemment derrière tout ça c'est pas
juste pour la passion des professeurs
qui encadrent qui encadre tout ça
absolument absolument lié tout un outil
de gestion de production qui va se
mettre en place d'audits de qualité et
puis une relation avec le monde
professionnel au travers du gifas
travers du rsa chose qui permet aux
élèves de grandir et puis de voir autre
chose que l'établissement stricto sensu
certains disent pas indispensable
aujourd'hui danser
véritablement via ces méthodes là de
pratiques et d'impliquer les élèves en
dehors d'un cadre purement scolaire
c'est presque vital pour nous c'est
presque vital pour nous il faut être en
mesure de leur proposer de montrer aux
élèves dire qu ils peuvent déboucher
quand vous dites vital sinon ces
filières la matière devrait plus les
élèves ce sont des filières qui sont
méconnus
on a fait venir l'année dernière au mois
de juin des parents d'élèves pour
présenter la filière maintenance des
équipements industriels et lorsque les
parents sont déjà sont entrés sur des
plateaux il n'avait aucune idée ce que
pouvait être un plateau de maintenance
on a souvent une image avec une personne
qui en bleu de travail avec une grosse
clé anglaise et une burette d'huile faut
savoir ce sont des jeunes qui
travaillent essentiellement sur un
support informatique et que les ateliers
les plateaux techniques sont d'une
qualité exceptionnelle
donc c'est une filière qui est méconnu
qui gagnerait être être davantage
connues et attendues pour la faire
connaître vous multipliez tout convient
de mentionner avec le club
d'aéronautique d'aviation de
l'établissement beaucoup de projets dans
cet établissement louis blériot attrape
alors on quitte ce domaine de l'aviation
et de lancer de fusées
vous participez aussi cette année à
euros scola la france vous allez la
représenter au siège du parlement
européen à strasbourg en quoi consiste
ce véritablement cette opération cette
opération consiste en une session
parlementaire organisée pour les jeunes
représentent enfin d'aider des lycéens
représentants de leur pays donc les
jeunes des 27 pays de l'union européenne
vont se retrouver au mois de
novembre à 23 97 23 novembre tout à fait
pour débattre de sujets aussi variés que
la contenir la la mixité large et
quelques-unes des des thématiques à la
place des valeurs de l'europe dans le
monde dont la création à l'intégration
environnement énergies renouvables 21
élèves du lycée qui vont participer et
également des élèves des 26 autres pays
de l'union tout à fait n comment vous
avez choisi ses élèves ils sont
volontaires alors c est leur font faire
des ti de d'action de qui sont qui
repose sur l'ouverture européenne
on parlait du rock est riche à linge il
faut savoir sur cette épreuve là il y à
une présentation d'un dossier technique
qui est effectué en partie en anglais
lors de la finale internationale
certains de nos élèves vont faire leur
période de formation en milieu
professionnel à l'étranger
c'est un plus énorme pour eux de pouvoir
présenter sur un cv une période de stage
effectué à l'étranger
on a aussi des classes qui travaillent
sur l'it winning lee twinning c'est un
mode des changes de partage entre
différentes écoles de différents pays de
la communauté européenne et qui peuvent
reposer sur différentes thématiques
sachant que on peut utiliser pour ces
échanges la une langue qui est commune
qui est l'anglais donc on a actuellement
plusieurs classes qui se sont déjà
inscrits sur ce projet là on a des
classes de cp qui participent cette
année encore sur un projet etwinning
donc on nous avons décidé de choisir nos
élèves sur ce qui était déjà inscrit
dans une dans une action d'ouverture
européenne
donc ça nous fait à peu près 21 élèves
donc le 23 novembre euros scola tout en
revenant à strasbourg parlement européen
tv fil 78 12 suivra d'ailleurs on
viendra voir comment se passent les
échanges avec les différents élèves de
l'union européenne dont ceux de
l'établissement de trappes on va juste
regarder un chiffre à présent qu'ils
restent dans cette thématique de
rencontres d'échangés entre jeunes en
europe 25 25 ans cette année nous fêtons
les 25 ans du programme erasmus des
changes entre étudiants de l'union
européenne un programme qui pourrait
pourtant disparaître faute d'argent vous
l'avez peut-être entendu les 27 pays
membres doit de l'union européenne
doivent développer une enveloppe de 132
milliards d'euros
ils ne sont prêts pour l'instant
l'inversé que 129 fumée
art dans la tente d'avancer nous avons
voulu savoir ce que vous pensiez de ces
échanges c'est notre question du jour à
quoi servent les échanges entre jeunes
européens mais ça permet au moins de
connaître d'autres cultures c'est ça le
plus essentiel pour moi et puis les
langues aussi peut être pratiqué
beaucoup mieux les langues
parce que ça on n'est pas très forts
pour ça va mieux se connaître entre pays
entre jeunes européens
obama à maintenir une tirer une
connaissance entre chaque pays et c'est
important ça et puis une connaissance
qu'ont les jeunes que nous n'avons pas
nous ce que nous n'avons pas connu ça
nous on a connu qu'au contraire des
différences et pas des ressemblances
ben je pense que c'est profitable pour
toute la jeunesse ça forge la culture ça
apprend à connaître l'avis des autres à
échanger sur la culture et sur la langue
notamment puisqu'on sait que en france
beaucoup de mal avec les langues
étrangères donc donc c'est étrangères
donc ça pourrait permettre à prendre
peut-être plus facilement la culture et
la langue d'autres pays ont parlé de ces
échanges erasmus pendant le
micro-trottoir vous me disiez vous êtes
un petit peu des victimes aussi de toute
apparition et de réduction de ses
budgets européens
nous étions nous inscrire sur un projet
comme innus donc un projet des changes
non seulement entre enseignants mais
aussi entre élèves avec des élèves qui
seraient allés découvrir un autre pays
est effectivement donc que notre
candidature nationale nous a été retenu
mais nos partenaires nos candidatures
n'a pas pu être retenue du fait de
problèmes financiers et toujours sur
cette action de d'ouverture vers
l'europe
j'ai plusieurs enseignants qui se lance
sur la validation de ce qu'on appelle
une une dn1 être capable de pouvoir
enseigner à voir l'habilitation pour
enseigner leur discipline dans une
langue autre que le français et
plusieurs enseignants s'inscrivent sur
sept dans cette action il y en a six qui
vont partir en irlande la prochainement
justement pour obtenir cette
certification qui nous permettra par la
suite devrait la section européenne qui
sont un plus évident pour un
établissement tel que le nôtre et qui
sont une fois de plus vital vital c'est
le mot vous avez employé au cours de cet
entretien vital véritablement parce que
les élèves qui vont sortir de votre
établissement
voulait qu'ensuite ils faisaient des
références et et que l'établissement
louis blériot de trappes soit une
référence pour les employeurs potentiels
après on s'y attelle et on s'y est elle
même avec un autre projet sous jacent
sachant que dans un établissement
d'enseignement professionnel vous avez
certains élèves qui ont un potentiel qui
n'ont pas encore pu exprimer et nous
sommes actuellement en train de
travailler avec l'iut de menthe et avec
le lycée jean-perrin de cintres l'aumône
sur une poursuite d'études qui aille au
delà de la poursuite d'études
traditionnel pour les élèves de bac
professionnel
un élève qui poursuit ses études
généralement bac professionnel de
s'orienter soit vers une mention
complémentaire soit vers un bts
on voudrait pouvoir proposer nous à
certains de nos élèves ciblés repéré une
possibilité de poursuite d'études vers
un iut voir vers une classe préparatoire
aux grandes écoles
tsi qui s'adresse normalement aux élèves
qui sont issus de la filière
technologique
sachant que on ne veut pas précipiter
les choses on prend le temps de
travailler avec nos partenaires
l'idée ce serait de pouvoir on a déjà
commencé à le faire commencer à repérer
un petit groupe d'élèves qui eux
auraient ce potentiel l'a aidé et
accompagné pendant toute leur scolarité
sur le blériot sur des temps forts sur
un accompagnement spécifique avec nos
partenaires à savoir l'iut et le lycée
jean perrin pour leur permettre de
pouvoir envisager une poursuite d'études
plus ambitieuses que celles qui
n'avaient envisagé au départ donc
classes préparatoires aux grandes écoles
iut développement aussi création d'un
avion ce que vous nous avez mentionné
tout à l'heure à la compétition au
quatrième renouveler encore cette année
avec et d'autres élèves j'en oublie
encore euros scola dont on a parlé ce
soir beaucoup de projets pour cet
établissement louis blériot merci à tous
les deux d'être venu nous en parler et
puis on suivra votre actualité
régulièrement actualité très chargée
vital pour l'établissement pour se faire
connaître et pour montrer que du côté de
trappes du côté du lycée louis-blériot
les élèves travaillent et travaillent
plutôt bien merci
et donc d'être venu en plateau dans un
instant la chronique sport dont anthony
rech comme chaque lundi juste après ce
reportage de valérie auribeau elodie
moines elles reviennent sur les assises
de l'éducation qui se tenait aux
clayes-sous-bois au coeur des
discussions l'organisation de la vie
scolaire mais aussi du temps en dehors
de l'école
quelle école et quelle éducation pour
demain vaste question posée par la
mairie des clayes-sous-bois lors des
premières assises de l'éducation pour en
débattre enseignants éducateurs
directeur d'école
aussi quelques parents s'étaient réunis
à l'espace philippe noiret en expert
jean claude guérin ancien inspecteur de
l'éducation nationale animait le débat
c'était une volonté justement de vouloir
odeur de réunir tous les partenaires non
seulement l'éducation les partenaires de
l'éducation nationale mais tout ce tous
les partenaires qui gravitent autour de
l'enfant pour justement prendre l'enfant
dans sa globalité et ne vais pas divisé
en sections les différents moments d'un
enfant par exemple au cours d'une
journée de la petite enfance à l'école
en passant par les loisirs sportifs et
culturels
il s'agissait pour les débatteurs de
prendre en compte chaque moment de la
journée de l'enfant la ville des clés
fut déjà précurseur dans l'aménagement
du temps de l'enfant à l'école victor
hugo afin d'apporter un autre regard de
l'enfant sur l'école la ville avait
proposé après la pause déjeuner un temps
loisirs sport culture et théâtre avec
différents intervenants
ces premières assises était l'occasion
d'une autre réflexion il faut les
implications départ on s'est tous parce
que les smartphones sont pas passées
ainsi à pas si on laisse
que dans l'école faire le travail des
parents ça va pas aller donc au coeur de
son élevage l'école d'aujourd'hui déjà
très bien a bien organisé on peut
l'améliorer c'est clair il n'y a pas que
l'école améliorée il ya tout le tout
l'environnement et les parents en
particulier on peut l'appliquer dans
l'école mais on peut aussi exiger d'eux
qu'ils aient aussi les mêmes objectifs
que l'école ce matin on a parlé de
manière très très général de delà de
l'enfant dans sa globalité et m'ont
trouvé dans la position de chacun la
position bas de l'éducation nationale
des enseignants mais aussi le rôle
qu'ils ont des départs en écho au delà
de tous les intervenants qui viendront
pour pour se compléter un débat très
philosophique de prochaines assises ne
sont pas prévues pour l'instant